Und nicht nur Rechner, sondern wir wissen ja auch, Faxgeräte, digitale Anrufbeantworter, Handys, jede Art von informationstechnischem System wie Ihre Bundesregierung.
Auch, denn quasi übermorgen auf der IFA angucken kann, wie sowas funktioniert. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Anfang des Jahres gab es das Gesetz, also bzw. den Beschluss über das Gesetz. Dann wurde gesagt, ja, wir sind Trojaner, wir gucken erstmal, was da passiert, und heute kam raus, das Ding gibt es zumindest in Grundzügen, es soll wohl funktionieren. Und es gibt schon einige Details dazu. Dazu gibt es ein Papier mit vielen Fragen und Antworten. Es wurde heute veröffentlicht und sorgt für eine Menge Wirbel. Der Chaos Computer Club konnte sich heute vor Anfragen kaum retten. Deswegen ist es umso schöner, dass wir euch beide hier für eine Weile zu Gast haben, damit ihr eure Fragen beantwortet unter 0331 77 97 110. Zum Beispiel die von Florian aus Neukölln. Nament Florian.
Ja, also nachdem sehr viel Negatives über den Bundestrojaner gesagt wurde, möchte ich doch mal ein bisschen eine Gegenposition vielleicht dazu einnehmen.
Wir warten schon eine ganze Zeit drauf.
Ich habe mir nämlich mal so vier Sachen glaube ich überlegt, die eigentlich ganz gut an den Bundestrojaner sind, die man vielleicht mal herausstellen sollte. Einerseits ziehen wir vielleicht überhaupt, ziehen wir denn die richtigen Schlüsse aus allen dem, was schon heute gesagt wurde. Es hieß ja zum Beispiel, spioniert wird sowieso von den bösen Leuten, von den Chinesen oder von den Amerikanern in Deutschland.
Dass das die bösen Leute sind, habe ich nicht gesagt.
Na gut, das habe ich jetzt einfach mal so gesagt. Also oder auch halt von bösen privaten Individuen. Also wer es will, kann es einfach machen. Und der Bundestrojaner würde ja derzeit noch eingesetzt, nach zumindest rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien noch, ich weiß, da kommen bestimmt gleich die Gegenargumente für.
Nein, nein, lass uns erstmal die vier Argumente hören. Also wir wollen dich da gar nicht...
Also, ich spiele jetzt jetzt sowieso. Warum die Bohnen? Dann, wenn ich jemandem Beweise unterschieben möchte, dann versuche ich dem doch quasi einen Rauchen im Kold unterzuschieben. Und so ein Bundestrojaner, da bekommt man ja eigentlich nichts, wo wirklich handfest ist. Da bekommt man ein paar Dateien, da kann man sich irgendwelche Dokumente oder irgendwelche Konversationen vielleicht rausziehen. Aber wenn ich jemandem wirklich was unterschieben wollte, dann nehme ich doch nicht einen Bundestrojaner dafür. Also das ist eigentlich, da gibt es bessere Möglichkeiten für, dem was unterzuschieben.
Zum Beispiel?
Na, indem man einfach was in der Wohnung platziert.
Oder muss er aber da einbrechen.
Naja, das muss man eventuell für die Platzierung des Bundestrojans ja auch.
Aber nicht physisch. Achso, du meinst, dass jemand in die Wohnung einbricht, mit einem USB-Stick oder einer CD in den Regen schiebt?
Oder einen Keylogger in die Tastatur einbaut und den später wieder abholt. Das sind ja auch mögliche Szenarien für die Anbringung. Also der ist vielleicht gar kein guter Rauchener Colt. Dann ist es vielleicht auch ganz positiv, dass das Bewusstsein dafür geschaffen wird, überhaupt durch den Bundestrainer, dass das EDV-Spionage stattfindet. Das heißt, dass das erstmal richtig bei den Leuten überhaupt ankommt. EDV-Sicherheit, dass das Bewusstsein für EDV-Sicherheit dadurch vielleicht gesteigert wird.
Ach ja, naja, mir persönlich haben da die chinesischen Trojaner-Angriffe zur Bewusstseinsbildung schon gereicht. Aber okay, ist das das dritte Argument, verstehe.
Aber ich glaub, das war erstmal schon...
Ich muss sagen, dass ich dein erstes Argument in Bezug auf die, du hast ja gesagt, ob wir die richtigen Schüsse ziehen.
Na ja, man kann jetzt leicht behaupten, der wurde eingesetzt, um politisch engagierte Menschen zu verfolgen. Ist ja nicht so. De facto wollen sie ihn ja erstmal einsetzen, um tatsächlich Verbrechen aufzuklären oder vielleicht zu verhindern.
Oder präventiv, also abzuwehren.
Zum Beispiel abzuwehren. So zum Beispiel auch hier die Verhaftung von dem Soziologen, die passiert ist, die ist ja wohl nicht einfach so passiert, sondern der wurde auch eine Zeit lang überwacht.
Ja und zwar vereinrohren, alle Möglichkeiten, die sie haben.
Und wurde dann in Untersuchungshaft gesteckt. Und jetzt wage ich ja einfach mal die These aufzustellen. Wenn die jetzt in dem Jahr, dass sie ihn überwacht haben, gar nichts gefunden hätten, hätten sie ihn dann einfach so habsnehmen können.
Naja, ist ja mittlerweile A, wieder entlassen. Und es ist ja so, dass... Und das ist doch das Argument von Monika Harms, der Generalbundesanwältin, die auch sagt, ja, ja, also wir hätten ja diese Hausbesuchung gar nicht machen können, wenn wir nicht was Handfestes hätten. Leider können wir es aber nicht sagen, was wir handfestes haben. Also wir werden warten müssen.
Und es gab ja immerhin die wissenschaftlichen Artikel, wo dieser bestimmten Begriff vorkam.
Begründet wird es ja damit, dass er also quasi Gedanken gut vorbereitet hätte und selbe Begriffe wie später in den Bekennerschreiben verwendet hätte in seiner wissenschaftlichen Arbeit und sich zusätzlich mit einem von den Menschen mal physisch getroffen hat.
Für alle, die nicht im Thema sind, was war das für eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit?
Der ist halt Soziologe und hat halt zu dem Bereich publiziert, mir sind die Arbeiten jetzt nicht bekannt.
Es geht um allgemeine gesellschaftskritische Ansätze.
Ja, also es ist nur so, dass er offenbar sich verdächtlich gemacht hat. Und an sich ist es ja grundsätzlich erstmal nichts Falsches, wenn man jemanden, der verdächtig ist, mal auf den Zahn fühlt an sich.
Also wenn man ganz kurz im Sprachbrot, also ob jemand verdächtigt wird oder ob sich jemand verdächtigt macht, ist ja vom Sprachlichen her schon nochmal ein ganz erheblicher Unterschied.
Wichtig ist ja, was du damit eigentlich meinst. Meinst du, das ist schon okay, wenn der so komische Papiere schreibt, dass sie mal seine Telefongespräche über Monate abhören, seinen Internetverkehr abhören und dann seine Wohnung besuchen und ihn verhaften? Willst du das sagen?
Ich möchte das schon so sagen, ja. Weil, gut, ich weiß, ob in dem speziellen Fall, ob das jetzt gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht, sei mal so dahingestellt. Aber im Grundsätzlichen, wenn zum Beispiel mal ein anderes Beispiel. Es hieß doch, dass die Anschläge vom 9.11. es gab da halt Hinweise, dass da was passieren könnte. Und wir sagen noch alle, hey, warum haben die nichts getan? Und wenn wir jetzt, wir wissen zum Beispiel, es gibt Gefährder in Deutschland und die sind verdächtig. Und die planen einen Anschlag und der wird dann durchgeführt. Dann werden wir hinterher auch sagen, hey, ihr habt das gewusst, warum habt ihr die nicht überwacht?
Warum habt ihr nichts getan? Du hast dir aber ein denkbar schlechtes Beispiel gesucht, weil ja seit Monaten bekannt ist, dass die gesamte Zelle, die in Deutschland aktiv war und Mohamed Atta sehr intensiv vom Verfassungsschutz observiert wurde und auch bekannt war. Also das ist jetzt auch die Argumentation, die du bringst, als wenn sie nur mit der Online-Durchsuchung erfolgreich sein können. Man muss einfach mal das Instrumentarium sehen, was die Geheimdienste und die Ermittler ohnehin schon haben. Sie schmorchen eh an allen Telefonen, die sie gerne wollen und hören Internetverbindung ab. Sie können dich geografisch lokalisieren. Sie können mittlerweile eine Kennzeichenerkennung an den Autobahnen machen. Sie tracken dich jetzt auch biometrisch. What else? Also die Online-Durchsuchung ist ja nur noch mal das Krönchen auf dieser Möglichkeit. Es ist ja nicht so, dass heute die Ermittler in den Büros sind und Däumchen drehen und nichts können.
Ja, genau, das ist vielleicht ganz richtig. Das ist einfach nur noch eine weitere Maßnahme. Und deswegen ist es vielleicht gar nicht gerechtfertigt, den Bundestrojaner jetzt so besonders hervorzuheben. Man muss ihn einfach nur als eine weitere mögliche Maßnahme betrachten.
Naja, es gibt ja einen Grund, warum der so hervorgehoben wird. Und der liegt natürlich in unserer Verfassung. Es gibt halt in dieser Verfassung Ewigkeitsrechte. Das heißt Rechte, die nicht eingeschränkt werden können. Und das ist unter anderem Artikel 1 die Menschenwürde. Und das Recht auf informationell Selbstbestimmung, nämlich das Recht jedes Bürgers darüber selbst zu bestimmen, was mit den privatesten Daten passiert, hängt halt an Artikel 1 in Verbindung mit Artikel 2. Das sind also Ewigkeitsrechte. Und deshalb ist der Eingriff so besonders stark. Weil gerade die jüngere Generation hat natürlich Privat-Teste-Daten auf diesem Rechner. Klar ist auch, dass über das Internet und über die privaten Rechner sehr viel intimste Daten verschoben werden. Filme, Bilder, Kommunikation. Der Eingriff ist halt sehr stark. Deshalb ist die Debatte stark.
Naja, ob die Qualität jetzt wirklich so viel stärker ist, als die einer Überwachung eines Telefonats. Man führt ja auch private Telefonate, in der Hoffnung, dass man nicht überwacht wird.
Aber das ist eine aktuelle Sache. Das heißt, da geht es ja nur um das Telefonat, was da geführt wird. Und nicht deine Arbeit der letzten 10, 20 Jahre durchsuchten, alle privatesten, intimsten Sachen, die nur niemand erzählen würde, sondern die du vielleicht nur in deinem Rechner auf dem Tagebuch geschrieben hast.
Ja, es sei denn, man wird schon seit 10 Jahren telefonüberwacht.
Ah, du kannst sich 10 Jahre telefonüberwacht werden.
Also so ein bisschen hinkt das gerade, Florian.
Also ich verstehe schon deine Argumente. Du sagst, lass uns die Terroristen fangen. Aber ob du nicht vielleicht schon ein bisschen der Propaganda aufgesessen bist damit. Also diese, na, es ist ja ein bisschen auch eine Angst, die geschürt wird. Also, dass hier um und herum überall Terroristen sind, das ist halt auch so ein bisschen geschürt. Das wird halt stark jetzt übertrieben. Also die ist ja fast schon eine Hysterie manchmal.
Was zum zweiten Argument, oder zum dritten Argument von Florian führt, der sagte, vielleicht wird dadurch aber auch eine größeres Bewusstsein dafür geschaffen, dass EDV-Spionage überhaupt möglich ist. Und dass man eben nicht hinter seinem Computer sitzen kann und dort allein in seinem Zimmerchen sitzt und das Gefühl hat, du bist zur Aline und da guckt ja keiner drauf. Dem ist ja nicht so.
Also an sich sollte es so sein und es ist eigentlich der Normalfall, dass ich da alleine sitze und keiner guckt drauf. Und wenn natürlich das allgemeine Gefühl da ist, der Staat überwacht uns ja sowieso ständig, sondern werde ich mich als Bürger auch dem entsprechend verhalten und das ist eine Gesellschaft, wo wir nicht hinwollen.
Man muss auch immer noch mal die Balance im Auge behalten. Selbst wenn es hier in Deutschland drei Zellen von Terroristen gibt, die sonst was für fiese Anschläge planen. Die Frage ist, ob ich aufgrund von so ein paar fehlgeleiteten Menschen, ob ich meine gesamte freiheitliche Gesellschaftsordnung ändern möchte für diese Spinner und ob ich ihnen da nicht eigentlich entgegenarbeite. Man muss einfach sagen, absolute Sicherheit kann es nicht geben. Wenn sich jemand auf irgendeinem Marktplatz oder sonst wo in die Luft springen will, dann wird man es de facto nicht verhindern können, wenn er so ein Ding an der Klatsche hat. Was gebe ich dafür auf und wo ist die richtige Balance? Ich finde, da muss man halt abwägen. Die Online-Durchsuchung ist halt wirklich ein starker Eingriff. Ich sehe auch an den vielen Leuten, die sich jetzt an den CCC wenden oder auch in der Uni bei mir, wie viele Leute sich da einfach Gedanken machen und wie unangenehm und wie derwertig ihnen das Gefühl ist, dass sie überwacht werden, wenn sie dahinsurfen, wo sie eben in ihrer Freizeit hin surfen. Sei es Porn oder sei es Flirt oder so im Netz.
Unter der Frage, wie viel Freiheit ist dir deine Sicherheit wert, wenn du das Gefühl hast, in einem sicheren Staat leben zu wollen. Wie viel von deiner privaten Freiheit möchtest du aufgeben? Das werden wir hier natürlich nicht diskutieren können, aber das sind alles Gedanken, Ansätze, die uns in den nächsten Tagen, Wochen und Monaten weiterhin beschäftigen werden. Dieser Bundestrojaner, um nochmal zum Thema zurückzukommen, dieses Papier, was heute veröffentlicht wurde, bedeutet noch nicht, dass das Ding wirklich jetzt schon unterwegs ist und ich morgen so eine Mail bekomme, wo der dann quasi auf meinem Rechen ist.
Also, nun, der Bundesnachrichtendienst setzt die ein. Es ist auch jetzt klar, in welchem Umfang die Geheimdienste dieses, diesen Bundestrojaner verwenden. Das sind so etwa, etwa sechs bis zehn. Da gibt es jetzt verschiedene Meldungen zu, aber der wird schon eingesetzt. Hier geht es darum, ob auch die normalen Ermittler, also jenseits der Geheimdienste, dieses Tool verwenden dürfen.
Also im Verfassungsschutzgesetz Nordrhein-Westfalen, die haben das Ende letzten Jahres beschlossen und das heißt also, die dürfen den auch einsetzen derzeit nach dem aktuellen Rechtsstand. Also es ist zwar auch eine Klage anhängig, aber solange bis die entschieden ist, dürfen die das.
Florian, dir erstmal vielen Dank für den Anruf. Du siehst, da kommen noch mehr Fragen. Wir hoffen noch mal ein paar von denen zu schaffen. Womit wir bei der nächsten Frage werden, die auch auftauchte vorhin schon mal im Vorgespräch. Was ist, wenn ich jetzt Gefühl habe, ich hab so ein Ding, wie wäre ich denn wieder los?
Na erstmal, man schickt ihn erstmal zu uns, damit wir ihn analysieren können und danach kann man ihn dann loswerden. Also ich darf da vielleicht mal aus diesem einen Satz, aus diesem sehr lustigen Katalog zitieren. Da ist nämlich dann die Frage, was passiert, wenn man keine Internetverbindung hat und wie soll man dann eigentlich diesen Trojaner wieder deinstalliert bekommen?
Also ich hab den auf dem Rechner und dann kappt sich meine Internetleitung und ich kriege ihn nicht raus.
Genau. Und die Antwort ist, durch eine für den Fall der erfolglosen Kontaktaufnahme, also ohne Internetverbindung, mit dem Steuerungssystem eingebaute selbst Deinstallationsroutine entfernt sich das Remote Forensic Software rückstandsfrei vom System.
Das klingt ein bisschen wie so ein Waschmittel.
Ja, also sie glauben echt, sie können da diesen ultimativem Trojaner bauen, der sich auch noch ohne jeden Zweifel selbst installiert, no matter what. Das ist halt schon richtig lustig.
Es ist natürlich schon realistisch, denn ist natürlich das einfachste Mittel, ich klänge meinen Rechner für ein paar Wochen vom Internet ab, dann verbindet er sich nicht mehr mit dem Steuerungsrechner und müsste sich dann theoretisch komplett weginstallieren.
Selbst die Installationsroutine klingt nach Star Trek, oder?
0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über den Bundestrojaner mit dem Chaos Computer Club auf. Fritz, der nächste am Telefon, ist Steffen aus Berlin. Hallo Steffen.
Meine Frage verzahnt sich ein bisschen mit der Frage, die Florian auch gestellt hat. Ich bin ein Anhänger dieses Argumentes, dass ich sage, wer sich nicht zu Schulden kommen lässt. Der hat auch nichts zu befürchten, wenn sich da Trojaner, egal von wem, auf seinem Rechner verzahnen. Das heißt, wenn ich als privater User eben, wenn tatsächlich jemand meine Daten ausspäht, ist es nicht jeder so ein Fachmann oder Fachloch, Fachmann wie die Leute, die jetzt vorher vor mir schon angerufen haben. Ich trete mich nicht zu diesen Fachleuten. Das heißt, ich wüsste nicht mal, wenn ich meinen Firewall, die habe ich veraktiviert, der erkennt auch Trojaner. Aber gut, dann klicke ich auf Deinstallieren und gut ist. Aber ganz offen, wenn er da drauf laufen würde, ich merke es nicht und die, die forsten meine Daten durch, gut, dann forsten sie sie eben durch, wenn ich mir aber nicht zu Schulden kommen lasse. Siehe ich nicht ein, warum nicht jemand auf meinem Rechner zugreifen sollte. Jetzt sagtest du selbst vorhin, den absoluten Schutz gibt es nicht. Siehe aber London, die Anschläge in der Innenstadt. Jetzt sagtest du, das ist noch der Motto, wenn es drei Kranke in Deutschland gibt und die planen Anschläge. Wenn ich aber ein Opfer dieses Anschlages werde, sehe ich die Sache vielleicht ganz anders. Wenn ich jetzt nämlich Opfer in London gewesen wäre oder ein Familienangehöriger von mir, würde ich die Sache mit den Online-Besuchern wahrscheinlich anders sehen. Ich würde es nämlich etwas stringenter sehen. Deswegen bin ich durchaus der Meinung, wenn das eine zusätzliche Maßnahme ist, um die Leute, die krank im Kopf sind, die solche Sachen planen, etwas enger zu schmüren, dann sehe ich durchaus kein Problem darin, solche Sachen zuzulassen. Ich weiß, dass das ein Totschlag-Argument ist, nach dem Motto, wer sich nicht zu Schulden kommen lässt, der gut, der kann es nicht.
Es ist überhaupt kein Totschlag-Argument. Ich finde das Argument von deiner Seite absolut berechtigt, weil ich habe auf meinem Computer auch weder irgendeine Bombe gebaut, noch sonst irgendwas gemacht. Also von mir aus, guck da drauf, du wirst sowieso nichts finden. Aber eigentlich möchte ich sowas nicht.
Selbst wenn ich da jetzt Pornos drauf habe oder Bilder aus meinem letzten Urlaub, dann gucken die sie sich an, aber die sind ja nicht, meine Bilder aus meinem letzten Urlaub sind ja nicht terrorverdächtig, dann gucken die sich an, stellen fest, aha, der hat keinen Dreck am Stecken, dann lassen sie mich wieder, sag ich mal, gehen oder machen keine weiteren Besuchungen.
Das ist ja schon im Prinzip fast die Umkehrung der Unschuldvermutung. Das heißt so hier bitte, ihr könnt ja gucken, ich hab nichts auf meinem Rechner.
Dann heißt es auch praktisch, sie können bei allem gucken und dann finden sie halt so ein bisschen wie im Minority Report, ja. Sie finden dann alle die, die auf ihrem Rechner schon böse Gedanken notiert haben und die ehrlichen Bürger, die machen einen neuen Start. Das ist halt eine Vision von Welt, die ich nicht möchte. Ich möchte auf meinem Rechner, selbst wenn ich Bock hab, schreiben, was ich möchte und möchte mich nicht deshalb zu einem Verdächtigen machen und ich möchte mich auch noch mit den Leuten und seien sie noch so politisch-kritisch treffen können, ohne dass ich plötzlich ins Visier der Ermittler gerate, nur weil ich mit den falschen Leuten telefoniere.
Du machst dich doch nicht verdächtig dadurch, dass du irgendwas auf deinem Computer tippst, was für dich privat vielleicht oder nach dem Motto Meinungsfreiheit, du kannst ja tippen, was du möchtest, wenn du dich nicht verdächtig machst. Aber wenn du dann irgendwann krank im Kopf wirst und du planst tatsächlich einen Anschlag, warum sollte der Staat nicht das Recht haben, auf deinem Rechner zuzugreifen und dich schon ausfindig zu machen und dich zu observieren, um dann, wenn du wirklich zuschlagen möchtest, das dann zu unterbinden?
Weil ich frei bin, zu denken, was ich möchte. Selbst wenn ich mir das überlege und mir konkrete Pläne mache, wenn ich sie in die umsetze, ist das nicht strafbar. Ich darf denken, was ich möchte. Und wenn ich in meinem Tagebuch schreibe, oh, der Schäuble, dem sollten sie den rechten Finger abhacken. Und in meinem Tagebuch schreibe auf meine Festplatte. Dann kann ich das einfach machen.
Dann bin ich aber noch nicht terrorverdächtig. Das ist ja ein bisschen sehr, sehr stark verallgemeiner. Wenn ich in meinem Tagebuch schreibe, der Schäuble ist doof. Und morgen überlege ich mir, ob ich ihn umbringe. Da kommt ja nicht der BND und köffst dann meine Tür und nimmt mich dann fest und sperrt mich für 10 Jahre weg. Das ist doch Quark.
Ja gut, aber du musst ja einfach überlegen, du kannst so eine Gesellschaft nicht komplett gedanklich voll überwachen. Das ist einfach nicht drinnen. Und wenn, dann ist es eine Gesellschaft, da träumen wir noch nicht mal von.
Man muss doch vor allen Dingen mal an den Missbrauch denken. Denk mal an die Fälle von Murat Kurnas und Al Masri. Zwei offensichtlich Unschuldige, die einfach aufgrund von solchen Daten weggesperrt wurden. Und zwar für Jahre. Also es gibt ja auch noch, man muss noch mal sehen.
Auf der schwarzen Seite, ja das ist richtig. Auf der anderen Seite sehe ich...
Aber kann dich natürlich nicht betreffen, nicht wahr?
Nein, na gut. Okay, wenn ich jetzt Murat Kurnas wäre, oder was auch immer, und ich sitze 10 Jahre hinter Gheddan, ist das scheiße. Wenn ich aber, jetzt muss ich mal anders argumentieren, was ihr vielleicht nicht so gerne hört, wenn ich damit aber 100 oder 1000 Menschenleben rette, die am Anschlag dadurch entgangen sind, wenn ich eben drei Murat Kurnas verhafte, und einer von diesen Murat Kurnas hat tatsächlich was am Dreck am Stecken gehabt, und ich rette damit 1000 Menschenleben, Es ist diese Luftsicherheitsgesetzdebatte, ob man also dieses Flugzeug abschließen kann, wenn man andere rettet, da gibt es ja bereits eine Entscheidung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, und hier ist ganz klar die ethische Abwägung, dass man nicht diese Leute abschließen kann.
Und zwar deshalb nicht, weil man nämlich in die Zukunft nicht sehen kann. Und was tatsächlich passiert wäre, ist halt nicht klar. Und man kann nicht präventiv diese Leben zerstören für die anderen, die man eventuell in der Zukunft rettet. Es ist eine interessante Debatte, aber sie ist halt, wir müssen die abkürzen jetzt, weil wir haben noch so viele Fragen.
Aber auch die Aspekte sind sehr interessant in dieser Diskussion, weil sie natürlich mal von der anderen Seite kommen. Deswegen, Stefan, dir vielen Dank. 0331 70 97 110. Nächste am Telefon ist Felix aus Berlin. Hallo Felix.
Na, ich wollte hier mal ein paar Details fallen lassen.
Lass mal die Details fallen.
Genau, also erstes Detail, Uhr umstellen reicht nicht. In den PDFs ist das eine der Fragen, was dann passiert, wenn die Systemzahlen ungenäutig sind.
Nein, du musstet etwas langsamer klären.
Langsamer und wir müssen mal vom Anfang an.
Ich kläre das ganz langsam. Also am Anfang meinte Frank, man könnte vielleicht den Trojaner loswerden, indem man die Systemuhr vorstellt.
Also das mein Computer sagt, heute ist nicht Dienstag, sondern Freitag.
Ja, also das ist ja eine Sache, die diverse Leute gerne tun, um irgendwelche Software, die nur bis Datum so und so läuft, zu machen. Das heißt, die Frage stellt sich eigentlich aus deren Sicht andersrum, was, wenn jemand immer die Zeit auf den selben Tag zurückstellt, damit irgendeine Shareware weiterläuft. So haben die das gedacht. Und was die sich überlegt haben, ist, dass sie ein zweites Modul in der Software haben, der die Zeit zählt, die diese Software schon läuft. Das heißt, wenn sich das Datum nicht ändert, dann wird das die zweite Zelle zurückgegriffen. Und die Idee dahinter wäre, dass man die Systemzeit vorstellen kann und es wirkt nicht. Aber auf der anderen Seite sagt das Gesetz auch, keine Maßnahme darf länger als drei Monate laufen. Und das heißt, die Sache, die ich vielleicht noch am ehesten denken würde, die man mal probieren könnte, danke an Starbucks übrigens für die Idee, dass man da die Systemuhr vorstellt und dann den Rechner ausmacht. Und die Uhr stellt man halt drei Monate vor. Und dann macht man den Rechner wieder an. Und das müsste eigentlich reichen. Aber ich meine, wir haben die Software auch noch nicht gesehen.
Kann auch aber einfach sein, dass sie sich aus dem Internet eine Zeit holen von einem Zeitserver irgendwo.
Ja, das machen sie nicht. Sie haben gesagt, sie machen keine Verbindung nach außen, weil man das daran detekten könnte, dass der Trojaner zerlässt.
Nee, nee, nee. In dem Fragenkatalog sind das schon spezifischere Antworten. Sie sagen schon, dass sie auch Dateien übertragen werden. Aber sie versuchen halt die Datenmenge zu minimieren.
Sie versuchen es vor allem dann zu machen, wenn du gerade eh auf das Internet zugreifst. Aber ich meine, der NTP, das ist auch eine extra Frage irgendwo, ob sie auf Zeitserver zugreifen, um sie zu synchronisieren. Sie haben gesagt, nein. Ihre Lösung ist, dass sie die laufenden Sekunden, die die Software schon läuft, zählen und dabei die Erweiterung nutzen.
Da kannst du ja vielleicht noch was dazu sagen, wie es dann wäre, wenn ich im Zuge eines Backups diesen Bundestrojaner mir auf eine externe Festplatte als Backup hole.
Genau, das hat auch jemand gefragt in den PDF-Katalog, was dann wäre, wenn man ein Backup einspielt und der Trojaner sollte sich schon deinstalliert haben und dann kommen sie halt auch damit, dass der so ein Timeout drin hat und sich praktisch selbst deinstalliert, wenn zu viel Zeit vergangen ist.
Also für mich quasi als technischen Halblein heißt das, dass so ein Ding ähnlich wie quasi eine kleine Taschenuhr dabei hat und schon zählt, wie lange er läuft und damit eigentlich relativ egal ist, wie lange der Rechner an ist.
Genau.
Alles klar. Oh, den hab ich verstanden. Danke Felix.
Dann schliegt vorhin jemand vor, man soll virtuell Maschinen benutzen, das reicht leider auch nicht. Denn also ein Detail in den PDFs, was ich relativ bemerkenswert finde, ist auch, dass sie gesagt haben, sie wollen im Zweifelsfall auch mal einbrechen und den Trojaner installieren. Also das heißt, sie wollen nicht nur über Internet den installieren, sagen wir E-Mail oder so, was jetzt immer durch die Presse gegangen ist, sondern in dem PDF steht sogar drin, sie wollen erst mal verdeckt einbrechen, also eine Hausdurchsuchung machen, um die Umgebung abzuklären, also um rauszufinden, welche Windows-Version überhaupt darauf läuft. Ja, und dann sagen sie aber auch, das war jetzt nicht in den PDFs, das war eine Frage im Internet, aber sie würden dann auch durchaus eine Hausdurchsuchung machen, um den Trojaner auf dem Rechner zu installieren. Und da geht man natürlich die virtuellen Maschinen mit. Also jetzt eine VMA-Aussetzung zum Surfen reicht auch nicht.
Das heißt also, der Tipp, den die Datenschutzbeauftragten heute gegeben haben, oder von gestern, dass man einfach noch einen zweiten Rechner nimmt, der dann quasi nicht am Internet verbunden ist, sondern komplett 100 Prozent offline, der würde dann eigentlich auch nichts bringen, weil dann kommen sie einmal installieren diesen Trojaner und kommen dann nochmal und holen die Daten wieder ab.
Ja, also online bezieht sich gar nicht so auf Internet, sondern online bezieht sich darauf, dass der Rechner weiter läuft.
Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt quasi einen Computer habe, auf dem meine Urlaubsfotos und der ganze Kram drauf ist, und das Ding war nie am Internet, sondern steht nur bei mir zu Hause rum, nützt mir das auch nichts?
Na dann könnten die trotzdem bei dir einbrechen und den Trojaner installieren und später wiederkommen. Das ist übrigens sowieso eine der Planungen gewesen. Schade, ich hielt das für eine gute Idee. Genau, also eine der Fragen war auch, kommt da nicht viel zu viel Daten zusammen? Und da meinten sie auf der einen Seite, ja, sie würden dann filtern, aber es heißt eben auch, sie könnten auch einfach das als Vorausbestimmung der Daten machen. Das heißt, sie lassen es halt einen Monat laufen, denken sich, naja, jetzt wird ja alle Passwörter abgerüstet haben, und dann machen sie eine offene Durchsuchung. Und dann ist zwar die Platte verschlüsselt, aber sie haben halt das Passwort abgerüstet.
Naja, genau, also und sie reden ja auch explizit dabei auch noch über Keylogger. Keylogger sind Software oder Hardware, in diesem Fall natürlich Software, die Tastatureingaben mitloggt.
Das heißt, wenn ich auf meine Tastatur einen Buchstabencode eingebe, gibt es irgendeine Software, die diesen Buchstabencode weiß?
Genau, oder auch eine Hardware, also es kann auch was sein, was in das Kabel zwischen Tastatur und Rechner eingebaut wird, ein kleines Stück Wasser aus der Stecker. Das merkt man dann nicht unbedingt. Und dann schwupp sind die Passwörter weg.
Die Fälle von bisher dokumentierten Online-Trojanern waren auch tatsächlich Keylogger, die sie in Internetcafés installiert haben. Und zwar durchaus Hardware. Also sie sind hingegangen, haben Tastatur manipuliert und haben dann später hingegangen und haben sich die Daten abgeholt.
Genau, also grundsätzlich nochmal, es geht bei diesem Bundestrojaner, auch wenn der Name noch so schön ist, es geht also wirklich um das ganze Repertoire an elektronischen Angriffen, auch gegen alle möglichen Geräte. Es geht auch selbstverständlich auch um Mobiltelefone. Es geht darum, dass, war ja auch so eine Geschichte, die in den letzten zwei Wochen oder drei Wochen aufgekommen ist, dass auch die Polizei schon gesagt hat, dass sie Mobiltelefone als Wanze benutzen wollen. Das ist eine alte Geschichte, scheint aber tatsächlich aktuell zu sein. Dass also auch selbst wenn das Gerät ausgeschaltet aussieht, dass dann das Telefon von außen angesprochen werden kann und als Wanze benutzt wird.
Felix, jetzt hast du dich ja offenbar ganz intensiv mit diesem Fragenkatalog befasst. Jetzt muss ich dich mal fragen, wie schützt du dich denn gegen den Bundestrojaner?
Ja, nicht ganz klar. Ich denke mal, wenn man Linienungszentrierte ist, ist man im Moment erstmal sicher. Ach, tatsächlich?
Würdest du das unseren Hörern als Ratschlag mitgeben?
Das würde ich unseren Hörern im Moment sagen, ja. Denn was sie bisher gesagt haben, ist alles dieartig. Linienungszentrierte ist man glaube ich erstmal sicher. Im Übrigen geben sie auch selbst zu in ihren Ansagen, dass der Online-Trojaner durchaus Fälle hat, wo er nicht funktionieren kann. Also sie machen erstmal eine Durchsuchung und überwachen ein bisschen und stellen dann fest, oh weia, der setzt was weiß ich FreeBSD ein, irgendwas was sie noch nie gehört haben. Und dann gibt es durchaus das Ergebnis, oh ja, der Online-Trojaner funktioniert nicht und dann gibt es auch noch irgendwie beugerhaft oder so. Also das ist durchaus vorgesehen als Ergebnis der Voruntersuchung, dass der Online-Trojaner nicht anwendbar ist in dem Fall. Und ich denke mal, das bezieht sich im Moment auf alles, was nicht windlos ist, aber das ist natürlich auch nur Vermutung.
Also du fühlst dich sicher. Diese Nachricht geben wir vielleicht unseren Hörern dann mit.
Also Linux allein reicht nicht. Man muss natürlich auch die Platte noch verschlüsseln, aber in der ersten Nährung würde ich sagen, ja.
Dann müssen wir unseren Hörern jetzt empfehlen, freie Betriebssysteme zu benutzen.
Hilft auch nichts gegen Keylogger, ne?
Aber bevor wir jetzt hier Puppendokter-Pille machen und ihr zuhört in der Zeit, wird Keylogger, Linux, freie, Dingsbummsplar, chaosradio.at. CCC.de ist die E-Mail-Adresse oder aber hier klickt fritz.de, die Webseite zum Sender, auf dem ihr gerade das Chaosradio hört, zum Thema Bundestrojaner und da werden wir es irgendwie hinkriegen, eure Fragen und eure Anregungen auch weiter zu leiten, weil wir werden auch nicht alle Leute in diese Sendung kriegen, die Leitungen sind wirklich ziemlich voll. Das heißt, weitere Diskussionen finden auch gerne in den entsprechenden Voranstalt. Jetzt machen wir es in den Nachrichten und danach geht es weiter.
Achtung! Closur muss leider krankheitsbedingt absagen.
Neu dafür auf der Bühne?
Und das hört man gleich drei nach 12.
Tausende Menschen haben angesichts der Waldbrände in Griechenland am Abend gegen das staatliche Krisenmanagement protestiert. Vor dem Parlament in Athen trugen die meisten der rund 8000 Demonstranten schwarze Kleidung, um an die 64 Todesopfer zu erinnern. Den Politikern warfen sie vor jahrzehntelang nicht, gegen Bodenspekulation und Brandstiftung vorgegangen zu sein. In Afghanistan haben die Taliban bis zum Abend zwölf ihrer südkoreanischen Geiseln freigelassen. Für die übrigen sieben endet ihre Geiselnahme wahrscheinlich morgen. Der Freilassung ging eine Zusage der südkoreanischen Regierung voraus. Sie sicherte den Taliban zu, ihre 200 in Afghanistan stationierten Soldaten wie vorgesehen bis Ende des Jahres abzuziehen. Trotz Kritik aller anderen Parteien besteht die Union auf dem Verbleib der letzten US-Atomwaffen in Deutschland. Man könne nicht vollständig auf die nukleare Abschreckung verzichten, sagte der außenpolitische Sprecher der CDU-CSU-Fraktion von Kläden, dem RBB-Magazin Kontraste. Im rheinland-pfälzischen Büchel sollen noch etwa 20 Nuklearbomben lagern. Der Chaos Computer Club zweifelt am technischen Sachverstand von Bundesinnenminister Schäuble. Es stimme natürlich nicht, dass Trojaner nicht entdeckt werden können, sagte ein Sprecher des Computer Clubs einer Zeitung. Schäuble hatte vorgeschlagen, die Computer von Verdächtigen zu durchsuchen, indem man ihnen ein Trojaner mailed. Im Rückspiel der Champions League Qualifikation hat Werder Bremen bei Dynamo Zagreb 3-2 gewonnen. Damit hat Werder die Champions League Gruppenphase erreicht. Auslösung dazu gibt's morgen. In der Nacht locker bewölkt oder klar, es bleibt trocken. Kühlt ganz gut ab auf 9 bis 4 Grad. Morgen ist es erst mal sonnig, später ziehen von Nordwesten her Regenwolken auf. In der Briegnis und der Okermark kann es dann auch ein paar Schauer geben. Es werden ansonsten allgemein 17 bis 20 Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz A12 Berliner Ringenrichtung Frankfurt-Oder. Lkw-Rückstau zwischen Frankfurt-Mitte und der Grenze. Ansonsten keine Störungen, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Heiliger Strosack. Diese Nummer ist so grottenalt, dass man eigentlich denkt, naja hol die hier alter Punk-Kram, aber so scheint doch ziemlich aktuell zu sein. Abwärts der Computerstaat aus dem Jahre 81 oder 82 glaube ich, vom Album Abwärts. Die Jungs sind übrigens wieder zusammenspielen, diese Wochen Konzert im SO36, aber das nur am Rande, denn wir sind hier nicht in der Musiksendung, sondern im Blumen auf Fritz. 0331, 7097, 110, Chaosradio Teil 127 zu Gast sind Constanze und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club. Und wir reden über den Bundestrojaner, denn heute ging durch die Medien, dass das Bundesministerium mehr oder weniger zugegeben hat, dass dieser Bundestrojaner am Start ist, sagt man wohl salopp dazu. Und es gibt einige pikante Details, wie das Ding jetzt konkret funktioniert. Und wenn ihr Fragen dazu habt, wie viele andere Menschen auch, dann ist das die Sendung, in der ihr diese stellen könnt, wie zum Beispiel Armin aus Berlin. Hallo, grüß dich. Deine Frage.
Ja, also ich hab jetzt von dem Freund, bloß von diesen Soziologen gesagt, es soll am Knast geendet sein. Könnt ihr hier das vielleicht nochmal ausführen, was da genau war?
Also ganz kurz, das geht um die, du hast ja wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, dass in Berlin oder im Umkreis von Berlin seit Anfang des Jahres eine ganze Menge Autos brennen. Verdächtigt werden einige Gruppierungen, eine davon ist die militante Gruppe MG. Und im Rahmen dieser Ermittlungen um die Brandstifter ist man auf einen Soziologen gestoßen, André H der kritische Texte schreibt, hinsichtlich Stadtentwicklung, Gesellschaft. Und man hat jetzt, das war sozusagen das I-Tüpfelchen, diese Ermittlungen, hat dann festgestellt, dass er mal Texte publiziert hat, wo anhand von einem Wortvergleich oder wo bestimmte Begriffe, typische Begriffe, also nicht typische, sondern bestimmte Begriffe, auch drin vorkamen, die auch an den Bekenner schreiben, von so einem Brandstift dann vorkamen.
Sie haben vor allen Dingen auch gesagt, die Bekenner schreiben seien intellektuell sehr anspruchsvoll und deshalb könne auch nur ein Wissenschaftler, wie er, der im Wort gewandt ist, überhaupt solche Texte verfasst haben. Also sie werfen auch eine gewisse geistige Urheberschaft davor. Es ist eigentlich schon das Ende vom Lied, also viel mehr haben sie nicht in der Hand, bis auf noch die eine Sache, dass sie sich eben mit einem derjenigen, die sie da festgenommen haben, bei einem Brandanschlag vorher getroffen hat. Also im Prinzip, zumindest was bisher veröffentlicht ist, ist eigentlich die Beweislage sehr gering. Und die Wissenschaftswelt, also vorneweg sogar die internationale Wissenschaftswelt, hat sich hier mit offenen Briefen an die Staatsanwaltschaft gewandt und hat gesagt, okay wir betreiben hier Wissenschaft, wir wollen nicht kriminalisiert werden für unsere Gedanken.
Und der kam dann schon in den Knopf, oder?
Na, der war in Untersuchungshaft und ist dann wieder freigelassen worden. Es kam noch mal zu einer zweiten Wohnungsdurchsuchung bei ihm, wo sie dann die eigenen Protokolle von ihrer ersten Durchsuchung gefunden haben.
Was mich da eigentlich mehr besorgt bei dem Ganzen, und da denke ich auch, das Fabri über den Typen, der in Guantanamo war, ist da nicht wie, kommen die eigentlich an die Information hin, sondern wie verwenden die die? Ich glaube, das ist mehr ein Problem der staatlichen Bildhür, als dass man mich wirklich beschappelt. Also wenn die mir auch auf dem Klo zuschauen, ist mir das relativ egal. Aber wenn die dann irgendwie die Information hernehmen und das dann verdrehen, naja, aber staatliche Willkür ist natürlich ein Problem, das kann man auch schon aus Schriften von vor 2000 Jahren ablesen, dass nicht all die Leute den Kopf verbrochen haben.
Sicher, und also ich denke natürlich schon, dass die angesprochenen Fälle von Al-Masri und Murat Kurnas natürlich Extremfälle sind. Man sollte die auf keinen Fall verallgemeinern, das wollte ich auch damit nicht sagen. Aber die Willkürfrage muss man natürlich stellen, vor allen Dingen dann, wenn es bei dem Bundestrojaner um eine heimliche Maßnahme geht, die hinter dem Rücken passiert. Wo ja normalerweise, wie jetzt an dem Fall von dem Soziologen, über den wir eben gesprochen haben, die Maßnahmen des Staates offen passieren. Hier ist es halt hintenrum. Und diese Heimlichkeit der Maßnahme wird auch so besonders kritisiert.
Wobei, ich muss sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es unbedingt Willkür ist. Aber es ist ja so, dass ich als Beschuldigter auch immer ein Recht habe, mich zu verteidigen. Es gibt gewisse rechtsstaatliche Spielregeln, gewisse Regulatorien. Und im Moment sind die einigermaßen im Gleichgewicht. Das heißt, es gibt irgendwie bei einer Durchsuchung, dann gibt es Protokolle, es gibt Zeugen und so was. Und das sind Sachen, die bei dieser Online-Durchsuchung, bei so einer heimlichen Durchsuchung dann plötzlich nicht mehr im Gleichgewicht sind. Das heißt, dass ich dann keine angemessene Möglichkeit mehr habe, mich zu verteidigen oder entsprechend auch für meine Entlastung wieder zu sorgen.
Wobei, naja, ich wundere mich ein bisschen, dass es dich nicht stört, wenn dich jemand auf dem Klo überwacht.
Wir hatten keine Klotüren, oder? So der 68er.
Ja gut, aber das ist dann quasi persönliche Befindlichkeit, ob man auf dem Klo zugeguckt werden möchte oder nicht. Das gehört doch gar nicht hierher. Der Grundpunkt der Diskussion...
Ich kann mich da nicht verteidigen. Nehmen die dann irgendwelche Informationen vom... Ist jetzt egal, ob übers Internet oder aufs Telefon, die hat dann irgendwelche Informationen und ich darf mich da nicht verteidigen, oder wie?
Dann sind wir ja bei staatlicher Willkür.
Dann ist das Problem eigentlich nicht, dass die mich abhören oder ins Internet mit reingehen oder was auch immer, sondern es ist das Problem einfach staatliche Willkür. Das heißt, meine Grundrechte, das ich mich verteidigen kann, gibt es halt da nicht mehr.
Natürlich, es ist auch die Argumentation der Juristen, dass man sich gegen eine heimliche Maßnahme, von der man nie erfährt, nicht wehren kann und den Rechtsfähigkeit nicht bestreiten kann.
Was einer der Hauptkritikpunkte ist an dieser ganzen Diskussion um den Bundestrojaner, dass du sozusagen nicht einen Brief bekommst oder jemand an deine Tür klopft, sagt, können wir bei ihnen mal gucken, hier ist der Durchsuchbefehl, sondern du kriegst gar nicht mit, wenn irgendjemand deine privaten Sachen durchsucht. Und da ist natürlich der Punkt, dass viele Leute sagen, soweit verlegen wir nicht. Armin, danke dir für den Anruf. Der nächste am Telefon ist Klaus, ebenfalls aus Berlin, mit einer absolut berechtigten Frage. Hallo Klaus.
Erstmal wollte ich mal an der Stelle loswerden. Ich finde das absolut beschissen und ein Eigentor, dass der Blumen nur noch zwei Stunden lang ist, gerade bei so einem Thema, aber es ist eine andere Sache.
Auch das ist was, was wir hier nicht diskutieren können und die sind jetzt zehn Sekunden Redezeit schon weg hier.
Gut, also die eine Sache war mal ganz praktisch. Ich bin nicht der Meinung, also wenn das, was ich weiß über Wohnraumüberwachung, du bist überhaupt nicht berechtigt als Überwachter, ein Überwachungstool oder jedenfalls keine Kamera oder Mikrofonen eigenmäßig zu entfernen, dann macht das keinen Spaß.
Das ist einfach schlicht nicht wahr. Das stimmt nicht.
Also ich denke mal...
Du kannst sie gerne mal nachlesen, das ist gut dokumentiert. Da gibt es ja viele Entscheidungen drüber, das ist nicht wahr.
Na gut, bin ich schon mal beruhigt.
Also solltest du bei dir in der Wohnung eine Kamera haben...
Und solltest du einen Bundestrojaner finden, kannst du ihn wirklich gerne an uns schicken. Du machst dich dabei nicht strafbar.
Du kannst den Pilesend an einem Auto auch gerne öffentlich versteigern.
Genau, oder auch zu uns schicken.
Ja gut, also ich glaube nicht, dass ich einen kriegen werde. Ich habe nämlich sowieso kein Internet im Moment. So, ich wollte eigentlich mal... Also es sind ja so viele Sachen gesagt worden, da haben sich mir die Haare gesträubt von ein paar Anrufer vorher. Da möchte ich erst mal sagen, ich glaube, also bin mir sicher, es geht da überhaupt nicht drum, irgendwelche Terroristen abhaft zu werden. Weil erstens mal, also wer wirklich da in dem Bereich professionell was macht, der wird weder irgendwelche offensichtlichen Dateis in einen Chat rumschreiben, noch auf seiner Festplatte haben. Ja, sondern also die Al-Qaeda-Leute, die haben ja wohl anscheinend mit Handzetteln gearbeitet. Also das macht jeder vernünftige Geheimdienst so. Dann verabredet man irgendwelche unterfänglichen Kennworte. Also glaube einfach, es geht darum, dass man da eher ein Instrument haben will, Leute massenhaft zu kriminalisieren. Und zwar, dass die Leute sich auch dran gewöhnen sollen, dass wirklich, wenn schon einer anruft und sagt, ist mir doch egal, ob die mich beim Scheißen filmen. Also dass man sich dran gewöhnen soll, jede Lebensäußerung muss überwacht werden. Dass jeder im Vorfeld verdächtig ist. Und wer was dagegen hat, der muss Dreck am Stecken haben. Und da möchte ich mal an Sachen, ich meine, das ist zwar nicht mehr modern, aber im Dritten Reich wurde sowas auch gemacht. Da wurden massenhaft Leute registriert und dann hat man die Gesetze geändert. Und was gestern erlaubt war, war plötzlich kriminell. Aber tausende von Leuten haben sich plötzlich auf der Seite befunden, dass sie einfach mal kriminell waren. Dass sie das Land nicht mehr verlassen konnten.
Viele der Traditionen, die sich bei uns gesetzlich herausgebildet haben, insbesondere auch im Verfassungsrecht, sind natürlich genau nach den Erfahrungen im Nationalstilismus geschaffen worden. Und auch um solche schlimmen Exzesse vom Gesetzgeber zukünftig zu verhindern. Natürlich. Niemand sollte vergessen, warum wir diese grundgesetzlichen Garantien haben, damit wir genau in so eine Situation nicht mehr kommen. Ich würde es aber nicht so stark überziehen. Ich würde nicht die aktuellen Regierenden mit den Nazis vergleichen.
Ich meine, es gibt hier Nazis auch in diesem Land, die noch was zu sagen haben. Ich frage mich halt, warum wird es zum Beispiel, wenn man massenhaft sich das Recht rausnehmen will, Leute zu überwachen, warum bringt dieser Staat es nicht fertig, die NPD zu verbieten?
Weil er sich unterwandert ist mit Fauleuten vom Staat.
Na ja gut, aber ich meine, das ist ja immer eine Sache, was für ein politischer Wille da ist. Und ich denke mal einfach, also zum Beispiel der Mensch, der vorhin angerufen hat, von den Londoner Anschlägen da gesprochen. Ich meine, ich finde das überhaupt keine legitime Gegenwehr, in der U-Bahn Bomben zu installieren und irgendwelche Leute im Berufsverkehr da in die Luft zu sprengen. Aber man kann doch nicht massenhaft Leute umbringen wie im Irak. Oder man kann ein Land in die Steinzeit zurückbomben wollen. Das haben sie offiziell gesagt, wollten sie halt in Vietnam machen damals. Haben sie auch versucht, die Kuppel, die laufen da heute noch um. Und dann kann man sich wundern, wenn die Leute irgendwann zurückschlagen. Und dann sagt man ja, wir wollen uns nur verteidigen. Und ich meine, ich denke mal, Leute, die solche Maßnahmen wie Schäuble fordern, die wissen schon ganz genau, warum sie so eine Überwachung vielleicht brauchen könnten in Zukunft. Und das sind auch immer so Dammbrüche, das sind immer Sachen, da werden total übertriebene Forderungen gestellt. Dann kommt das Verfassungsgericht, relativiert das ein bisschen. Aber die Entwicklung läuft doch immer genau in diese Richtung. Also zum Beispiel mit der Autobahn.
Warte mal, Klaus, warte mal. Wir machen jetzt hier ein Fässchen nach dem anderen auf, die auf keinen Fall mehr zu schließen sind in dieser Sendung. Deswegen wirklich bitten, dich da auch kurz zu fassen oder dich zu präzisieren, weil ansonsten kommen wir hier vom Hundertsten ins Tausendste und wir haben noch original 10 Minuten Sendung. Und wie du selber festgestellt hast, dauert der Blumen noch zwei Stunden und damit war es dann vorbei. Also um deine Argumentation ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, sagst du, dass diese Art und Weise der Überwachung, die jetzt mehr oder weniger geplant ist oder in der Pipeline ist, eine Art Dammbruch darstellen könnte. Ich werde genau in diesem Konjunktiv formulieren, ob es soweit ist, können wir alle nicht voraussehen und wir hoffen nicht, dass es soweit kommt.
Wir können doch immer noch hoffen, dass sich das Bundesinnenministerium besinnt und von dieser Ausspionierung mit diesem Trojaner absieht.
Sagen wir mal so, das Dammbruch, das wäre auch so ein Ding, was ich mal erwähnt hätte. Also das kann man eigentlich sagen, dass es andauernd versucht wird. Und gerade seit dem Herrn Schäuble, aber nicht erst seitdem. Und ich habe halt immer das Gefühl, wenn ich auch die Anrufer manchmal höre, es gibt überhaupt kein sowas wie ein demokratisches Bewusstsein, gibt es bei vielen Leuten vielleicht gar nicht mehr. Deswegen werden solche Sachen versucht. Also Autobahnmaut, jetzt wird jeder Pkw das Kennzeichen fotografiert. Anfangs hieß es, wir wollen Gebühren erheben, dann wollten wir Schwerkriminelle fangen. Also das sind einfach Sachen, wo jede Woche was passiert. Wo Leute sagen, ich hab nichts zu verbergen.
Ja, und damit sind wir jetzt, ich fahre jetzt ganz fies dazwischen, damit sind wir bei der Autobahnmaut, da wollten wir eigentlich gar nicht hin. Aber um mit Leuten darüber zu reden, was Demokratie eigentlich ist und was jeder in diesem Staat machen wollen und dürfen kann, dazu machen wir auch Sendungen wie diese. Danke dir für deinen Anruf. Ja, wie gesagt, wir haben noch 10 Minuten, also quasi nicht mal mehr so viel, weil der Night Flight steht auch vor der Tür.
Also wir haben eigentlich noch eine ziemlich wichtige Sache, das geht nämlich um die Benachrichtigungspflicht. Das heißt, wenn bei mir so eine Maßnahme stattgefunden hat, sei es eine Telefonüberwachung, sei es eine heimliche Online-Durchsuchung, was auch immer, dann gibt es immer Regelungen in den Gesetzen, dass der Betroffene benachrichtigt werden soll. Das heißt, lieber Herr, Frau, Sie haben bei Ihnen, hat diese Maßnahme stattgefunden.
Das wird im Nachhinein gemacht.
Das soll im Nachhinein gemacht werden. Und das Problem ist, das steht eigentlich drin, also es müsste eins, aber die Praxis zeigt, dass es häufig immer mal wieder gerne vergessen wird oder aus irgendwelchen taktischen Gründen dann nicht gemacht wird. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem bei all diesen Maßnahmen.
Man muss es eigentlich sogar noch krasser formulieren. Es ist eigentlich so, dass nur sehr, sehr wenige von diesen Maßnahmen jemals erfahren, das heißt, die Benachrichtigungspflichten werden eigentlich so gut wie überhaupt nicht erfüllt. Also sind in vielen Bereichen immer nur so 10, 15 Prozent, die jemals erfahren.
Wie ist das Prozedere, wie geht es jetzt eigentlich weiter? Also Anfang des Jahres gab es die Gesetzentscheidung, dass dieser Bundestrojaner installiert oder erfunden werden soll. Heute, seit gestern ist klar, das Ding gibt es. Es funktioniert zumindest in Grundzügen. Jetzt wird des Weiteren drüber diskutiert zwischen SPD und CDU, wie jetzt die konkreten Maßnahmen aussehen sollen. Ab wann ist das Ding einsatzbereit? Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ja, also beschleunigt ist es noch nicht, sondern es geht jetzt um dieses BKA-Gesetz, also ein spezielles Gesetz, was dem Bundeskriminalamt bestimmte Befugnisse bei der Terrorabwehr zusprechen soll.
Und präventiv.
Präventiv auch. Und das steht jetzt gerade zur Diskussion. Und die große Frage ist, ob diese Online-Durchsuchung in dieses Gesetz mit reinkommt oder nicht.
Und da umgeht sich auch der Streit innerhalb der Koalition.
Weil die einen sagen, nein, wir wollen es nur als Paket verabschieden. BKA-Gesetz ohne die Online-Durchsuchung macht keinen Sinn. Und die anderen sagen, ne, also wir müssen es jetzt nochmal diskutieren. Da scheint es offensichtlich erheblichen Diskussionsbedarf zu geben. Und lass uns doch erstmal das BKA-Gesetz ohne verabschieden.
Also das ist aber einfach so, dass seit eigentlich seit Wochen das BKA und auch die BMI von seiner Seite sagen, da gibt es nichts zu debattieren. Wir müssen diese Online-Durchsuchung haben. Wenn nicht, verbiegen wir uns auch die Verfassung, falls es nicht grundgesetzkonform ist. Also sie wehren auch diese Debatte ab, die eigentlich ganz wichtig ist, die wir mal brauchen.
Dass es nichts zu debattieren gibt, haben wir in den letzten zwei Stunden gesehen. Wir werden auch nicht mehr alle Anrufe schaffen. Wahrscheinlich noch Björn aus Parchin. Bevor wir mit Björn reden, an euch beiden nochmal die Frage, um es zum Schluss nochmal zu präzisieren, was kann ich machen, welches Gefühl, aber ich hab so ein Ding.
Natürlich, wir brauchen ganz dringend dann diesen Bundestrojaner zum Analyzieren beim CCC. Und danach, ich würde ihn einfach doch eher entfernen, man kann natürlich darüber dann auch gezielte falsche Informationen verbreiten. Also wenn man jetzt weiß, man hat diesen Bundestrojaner, dann kann man ja auch lustige Informationen an die Ermittler geben.
Die Porno-Sammlung, dass ihr auch was zu lachen habt.
Ja, damit die was zu gucken haben. Die Porno-Sammlung, wir haben doch keine Porno-Sammlung auf dem Rechner.
Ihr bringt mich in Teufelsküche vorhin, wenn ihr das CCC erfüllt habt. Nein, Quatsch. Björn aus Parchim, hol uns mal da raus. Hallo Björn.
Ja, was wollte ich dazu sagen? Also mein Statement zu der Sache Bundestrojaner ist, eigentlich, dass es nur das Gründchen ist.
Was sagst du das?
Ich bin in der DDR geboren und verfolge seit Jahren die unrechtbeginnen Diskussionen vom Überwachungsstaat. Und muss ganz ehrlich sagen, nachdem was heute in der demokratischen Gesellschaft abgeht, das ist einfach für mich unfassbar. Also da wird über ein System hergezogen und das heutige ist meiner Meinung nach absolut nicht ein Stück besser. Es ist nur wesentlich subtiler und versteckter, als es früher gewesen ist.
Hast du denn außer dieser Online-Durchsuchung jetzt mal gesehen, was sich noch so in diesem BKA-Gesetzentwurf befindet? Also wie siehst du die anderen Möglichkeiten, die sie jetzt den Ermittlungsbehörden einräumen wollen außerhalb von der Online-Durchsuchung?
Also ich sag mal so, da kann ich auch ganz einfach zu sagen, früher ist es so gewesen, da sind Leute in eine Wohnung eingebrochen und haben irgendwo eine Wanze installiert. Dieses System hat es erfolgreich geschafft, dass jeder Bürger seine Wanze freiwillig bei sich trägt. Das zeigt alleine dieses Beispiel, ich telefoniere mit euch über ein Handy. Man darf auch nicht vergessen, was das gigantische Zusammenspiel ist zwischen Politik, Geheimdiensten und Wirtschaft. Also was haben wir noch für Möglichkeiten?
Die Möglichkeit, die du hast, ist, dass du als mündiger und schlauer Mitglied dieses Landes und dieser Gesellschaft dich darüber informieren kannst, was hier eigentlich alles läuft und dir jegliche Informationen beschaffen kannst um dich über solche Geschichten zu informieren, wo es dann schon eindeutige Unterschiede zum Thema DDR gibt.
Ja gut, aber andererseits macht es uns auch handelsunfähig, wenn ich als Gruppe von fünf Leuten irgendwo stehe und angeregt diskutiere und als verfassungsfeindliche Organisation eingestuft werden kann.
Als Mitglied einer terroristischen Vereinigung meinst du?
Zum Beispiel.
Also ich meine, es ist schon alles ziemlich scharf und ich denke mal einfach, dass der Terrorismus als Vorwand benutzt wird, um da jetzt gewisse Interessen zu verfolgen. Und wenn ich das jetzt so vergleiche System kritisch mal betrachte, dann kann ich nur feststellen, dass das Kind heutzutage einen anderen Namen hat als früher.
Na ja, es gibt einen kleinen Unterschied. Wir können sie abwählen, wir müssen es nur machen.
Ja, aber einer alleine reicht nicht.
Deswegen machen wir auch so eine Sendung hier.
Deswegen, die fünf Freunde, mit denen du diskutiert hast, red doch einfach mal mit denen drüber. Die fünf Freunde, mit denen du diskutiert hast, red doch mal mit denen einfach drüber. Beziehungsweise, und damit sind wir dann beim Abschluss dieser Sendung und kommen nochmal auf den 22. September zu.
Genau, du kannst nämlich auch noch deiner Stimme Gewicht geben und zur Demo kommen, damit wir denen mal zeigen, wie viele wir sind.
22. September, Brandenburger Tor, www.freiheit-angst.de Danke dir Björn, danke Frank, danke Konstanze.
Das war's Chaosradio Teil 127 zum Thema Bundestrojaner. Heute, wie gesagt, ganz aktuell kurzfristig reingeschoben. Das eigentlich geplante Thema, biometrische Datenerfassung und der biometrische Personalausweis, das schieben wir auf die Sendung Ende September. Und die ist wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Ihr könnt den Podcast der Sendung in den nächsten Tagen nochmal nachhören. Und zwar auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Dort gibt es auch ein Wiki und da gibt es ein Forum. Und da kann man Fragen stellen und sich ansonsten auch an den Chaos Computer Club wenden, wenn ihr da weitere Informationen haben möchtet. Hier auf Fritz geht es jetzt weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Wir sagen Tschüss und werdet nicht zu paranoid. Schlaf schön, ciao.